this video is brought to you by
brilliant problem solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach check
them out at brilliant dot org forward
slash bar graphics more on them in just
a bit without a doubt Robert Hooke was
one of the greatest minds in British
history his scientific contributions
spanned physics astronomy horology
microscopy paleontology and even
architecture and yet he is nowhere near
as well known today as some of his peers
the Royal Society believes that Hooke
scientific career can be split into
three parts first where the early years
when Hooke had the inquisitive mind and
the ambitions necessary to become a
great scientist then came the apex of
his profession around the time of the
Great Fire of London in 1666 his
architectural work redesigning and
reconstructing many buildings devastated
by the fire brought him great wealth and
lastly there is the third stage of
Hook's life where bitterness and
rivalries with other scientists
overshadowed his contributions and
ensured that he became just a footnote
of history but Robert Hooke wasn't
forgotten completely and today we take a
look at the man sometimes described as
the Leonardo da Vinci of England
Robert Hooke was born on July the 28th
or 18th going by the old star British
calendar 1635 in the village of
freshwater on the Isle of Wight the
eldest of four children - John her
concessive League ours for the first
part of his life Hooke was a frail and
weak child and his parents had little
hope that he would survive even so his
father took the time to provide him with
an education
John Hooke was a priest with the Church
of England Freshwater's Church of All
Saints he had two or three brothers who
were also ministers and expected young
Robert to follow in their footsteps
from an early age Robert Hooke showed
his families that he had other interests
he was fascinated with mechanical
devices and toys and enjoyed taking them
apart and putting them back together
again still a child Hooke built a ship
about a yard long which had proper
rigging and good sail and even had some
small guns that would fire on another
occasion he completely disassembled an
old brass clock to see how it worked and
created a functioning replica or out of
wood also during childhood Hooke picked
up another interest that would serve him
well in life and that was drawing the
story comes to us courtesy of the book
brief lives by 17th century writer and
natural philosopher John Aubrey this
indeed is one of the main sources for
Hookes early years a painter named John
Hoskins came to fresh water to draw
pictures for an unspecified nobleman
young Hooke saw him in action and wanted
to give it a shot he did not have the
right supplies so he had to improvise
Robert collected chalk coal and a
recognizer together and placed the
mixture on a wooden platter he then took
a pencil and began copying the pictures
that the family had around the house
[Music]
even though it became clear that Robert
would not go down the path of the church
like his father or his uncles but John
Hook still wanted to ensure that his son
had the means to pursue his profession
of choice at first it seems like hook
was destined to be an artist
he became an apprentice to sippy toll le
a Dutch painter who was one of the
premier portraitists of his time he also
studied with Samuel cameramen described
by Aubrey as the prince eliminar of his
age alumna was someone who illuminated
manuscripts I he decorated them with
drawings borders and initials hooks
foray into the art world did not last
long he discovered that the smell of the
oil colors exacerbated the headaches
that he had suffered from since
childhood so instead he enrolled at the
Westminster School in London and a
headmaster Richard Busby here Hooke
learns Latin and Greek and got his first
taste of geometry always looking to
expand his horizons Hooke also took an
interest in music and had 20 lessons on
the organ this was enough to secure him
a spot as a chorister at Christchurch
College in Oxford around 1653 there he
came under the influence of some of the
most accomplished scientists of that era
Robert Boyle dr. Thomas Willis john
wilkins christopher rep eventually he
enrolled to study at Wadham College hook
himself later described these Oxford
days as the period of his life which
cemented his love of science we do have
a limited knowledge of Hookes scientific
contributions during those early stages
he served as a chemistry assistant first
to Willis and then to Boyle according to
his journal Hooke designed and built an
air pump which Paul used in his
experiments with the pneumatic engine he
also came up with a variety of designs
which a lost history regarding the art
of flying he presented these to John
Wilkins who found them in practical but
ingenious hooks most significant
invention at the time though had to be
the anchor escapement this was a small
cog fitter to pendulum clocks which
helped maintain the swing and made the
clock more accurate by giving a small
push with each swing hook continued his
studies of timepieces as the years went
on and around 1660 also created the
balance spring for pocket watches we
should however mentioned that some
believed credit for this invention is
due to Dutch scientist Christian Wiggins
at the same time some historians argue
that Hooke deserves partial recognition
from
Boyle's law and experimental gas law
described named by his employer at the
time Robert Boyle the reasoning behind
this is that Hooke designed and built
most of the apparatus used in balls
experiments something importance
happened in 1660 the Royal Society was
born one of the oldest learned societies
still in existence today it eventually
became the first national scientific
society in the world unofficially it
existed for a couple of decades prior to
it becoming a formal organization and
receiving a Royal Charter from King
Charles the seconds initially a
consistent of various scientists who got
together to discuss ideas and
experiments most of them were part of
the Gresham College group whom as the
name implies met in Gresham College in
London eventually twelve of these
scholars formed a committee and founded
the Royal Society of London for
improving natural knowledge this was a
bit of a mouthful though so by the time
the King granted them their charter in
1662 they were already known simply as
the Royal Society with William
brokenness serving as their first
presidents now Robert Hooke was not
among the original 12 founders but some
of his friends and mentors were such as
Robert Boyle Christopher Wren and John
Wilkins therefore it wasn't surprising
that Hooke was among the first new
additions to the club in November 1660 -
he became curator of experiments at the
Royal Society
this was described as a position that
only Hooke could fill as he was required
to demonstrate three or four experiments
at every meeting and at first he wasn't
even paid to do it yet Hooke acquitted
himself marvelously of his duties as he
finally had a scientific outlet for all
the ideas he had accrued over the years
and as an audience he had his most
brilliant peers who are in the best
position to judge and appreciate his
work cook's contributions were one of
the main reasons why the society
flourished during its early stages
consequently he was appointed curate of
a life and also was granted another
position of cup Larian lecturer in the
mechanical arts so he may receive
another salary from funds provided by
Sir John Cutler and if this didn't keep
Hooke busy enough in 1665 he also became
the professor of geometry at Gresham
College now just before we get into what
he accomplished in that position I want
take a moment to tell you about today's
sponsor brilliance brilliance is a
problem-solving based website and app
with a rather hands-on approach they've
got over 60 interactive courses in maths
science and computer science you can use
brilliant to achieve your stem goals one
little bit at a time you'll expand your
understanding of the world through
interactive puzzles brilliant courses
teach you through storytelling
interactive challenges and problem
solving new brilliance are always
improving their platform and there's
brand-new interactive content that's
been added recently including updates to
their logic course as well as their
course on mathematical fundamentals or
if you want something completely new
brilliant to have a course all about
search engines which will teach you how
search engines like Google work they're
sort of behind the scenes stuff how it
finds that information you need for
billions of results in just a fraction
of a second
now brilliant is a great way to
complement watching educational videos
like this one and it will really help
you master even complex and technical
subjects so if you want to support by
graphics and get unlimited access to all
of brilliance in depth maths and science
courses head over to brilliant at or
forward slash buyer graphics and get 20%
of their annual premium subscription
let's hear back to hook
[Music]
among the many accolades we can ascribe
to Robert Hooke we can add the
popularization of microscopes to the
list in 1665 he published the first
major work in history on microscopy
titled micro gap here or to give it its
original full name micrographia or some
physiological descriptions of minut
bodies made by magnifying glasses with
observations and increase thereupon even
though the title was just a tad
long-winded the book was a hit it showed
the world that a Robert Hooke was one of
the preeminent scholars of his time and
it also helps solidifying the status of
the Royal Society as this was its first
major publication the politician and
famed dyrus samuel peeps labelled
micrographia the most ingenious book
that I ever read in my life
inside the book people could see for the
first time close amp'd detailed drawings
of insects and plants which were done by
hook himself therefore giving us a
glimpse at his skill as an artist as
well the images were accompanied by
insightful somewhat artful descriptions
perks most famous illustration the flea
for example was described as being a
little busy creature adorns with a
curiously polished suit of sable armor
and multitudes of sharp pins shaped
almost like porcupines quills some
entries were peppered with humour such
as the instance where hook described how
he got an ant drunk so that it might sit
still and allow it to be examined the
scientist claimed he gave the insect
brandy which knocked him down dead drunk
so that he became moveless the ants
revived and ran away about an hour later
it wouldn't be completely after the
questions a regard Hooke and his
micrograph here is a science
popularizers
trying to bring knowledge to the masses
a few centuries before his time the
microscope used for these examinations
was notable in and of itself Hooke did
not build it he outsource this task to a
famed London instrument maker named
Christopher [ __ ] Herc did modify and
refine it though by attaching a screw
operated focusing mechanism of his own
design as well as adding a water lens
which could aim a bright pinpoint of
light on the smallest of targets
another thing worthy of mention in
micrographia was the first use of the
biological term cell which denoted the
basic structure which all organisms are
made out of Hooke coins the word while
looking at a piece of bark from a cork
tree under his microscope he described
it as being
perforated and porous much like a
honeycomb it was made out of little
boxes which hook called cells because
they reminded him of the rooms that
monks had inside a monastery
micrographia was a perfect example of
how Hookes mind worked he was a man of
many interests and he developed them all
at the same time he wasn't one to just
focus his attention on one thing even
though the book was intended as a
presentation of microscopy it also
describes distant planetary bodies which
Hooke observed with his telescope it
also presented his examination of
fossilized woods and hooks associated
ideas which resembled an early version
of the theory of evolution he also
talked about the wave theory of light
and other scientific interests which had
nothing to do with the original purpose
of micrographia who also mentioned his
ideas on combustion at a time when other
scientists were adopting the theory of
phlogiston they fire-like components
which they thought existed in
combustible elements hooker Pines that
the process was determined by a
substance which was mixed with air
although this is pure speculation some
modern scholars believe that if I could
pursued this line of inquiry more
fervently he would have discovered
oxygen a hundred years earlier although
Hooke was undoubtedly a scientist he
actually made more money in his lifetime
from his side job as an architect on
September the 2nd 1666 London was
ravaged by a great fire which burned
down much of the medieval part of the
city the blaze lasted for five days and
consumed over 13,000 structures most of
them houses afterwards came the
monumental task of rebuilding the city
the duty and the ensuing accolades fell
on Christopher Wren someone who is
literally remembered as the man who
rebuilt London this is not without merit
Wren oversaw the construction of many
important buildings and structures
he designed 52 new churches including
his magnum opus sub Paul's Cathedral
Wren was aided in his endeavor by Robert
Hooke who served as his chief assistant
and the new severe to the city of London
but Rowan's name is inexorably tied to
the architectural landscape of London
Hookes contributions are seldom
remembered even though he surveilled and
certified nearly 3,000 new foundations
between 1667 and 1672 in his own time
John Aubrey gave her credit for building
the raw College of Physicians Bethlem
Royal Hospital and Montagu
housed among others even he did not know
the full extent of Hookes input merely
noting that Hooke was much made use of
when it came to designing new structures
it is hard to say with any certainty
what the dynamic was between the
partnership of Ren and hook some modern
historians even argue that hook was the
more important partner because it was
his expertise in mechanics which made
many of the new buildings possible we
will probably never know for certain the
extent of the influence that Hooke had
on the landscape of London hooks lasting
contribution to physics is the law of
elasticity the chances named Hookes law
states that the force needed to compress
or extend a spring by some distance is
proportional to that distance the
formula for this is F equals minus KX
where F is the force applied to the
spring X is the distance the spring
compresses or expands and K is the
spring constant which denotes its
stiffness the formula is typically
presented with a negative value to show
that the force exerted by the spring
opposes its displacement what might be
more interesting to us however was the
way in which Hooke presented his new
principle we're not exactly sure when
Hooke first came up with that speed had
made claims about developing it as far
back as 1660 but he published it in 1678
two years prior however he gave everyone
a teaser in another book of his titled
descriptions of hylia scopes he listed
ten new discoveries and inventions which
he intended to present in the near
future one of them was the true theory
of elasticity or springiness and a
particular exploitation thereof in
several subjects in which it is to be
found and the way of computing the
velocity of bodies moved by them see you
know Stu maybe this last bit is not a
typo it's actually an anagram and a non
pronounceable one of that two years
later he revealed that it meant root
tensio sic v s-- which was latin for as
the extension so the force you might
consider it a bit odds that hook went to
such lengths but it was not completely
unheard of in those days to conceal your
workings behind anagrams ciphers or some
other kind of hidden message the idea
was that by publicly presenting a theory
in this way the scientist established
priority without revealing too much
information
afterwards they were free to keep
working on that project for months years
or even decades until it was fully
fleshed out and ready to present the
world if in the meantime another
researcher unveiled the same idea
the initial scientists have proof that
they started work on the subject first
there are quite a few important
discoveries and inventions whose
originators are under doubt because
multiple scientists worked on them at
the same time
hence Hookes use of the anagram a
strategy that have been employed by
other scientists like Newton and Galileo
[Music]
as you can see Robert Hooke was
incredibly accomplished yet he enjoys
only a fraction of the renown of his
great contemporaries but why is that
well you almost certainly know that old
saying history is written by the victor
in this case it could simply be that
Hooke picked a fight with the wrong guy
setting aside hooks many talents it is
important to remember that he was still
a man full of foibles it seems that he
was particularly prickly when he
perceived that others tried to take
credit for something that he came up
with the problem was that Hooke often
moved on from one idea to another if he
did not perceive it to be important
enough or something that he could patent
and make a profit this meant that a lot
of his notions were undeveloped and he
never advanced past the stage of
scribbles on a piece of paper it would
be a little like crediting da Vinci with
the flying machine because he made a
drawing of one unsurprisingly there's
attitude led to several feuds with
fellow scholars we already mentioned in
passing that he and Christian Huygens
are used over who developed a spring for
watches first he also quarreled with a
German theologian and scientist named
Henry Oldenburg but Hookes greatest
rivalry one that had a profound effect
on his reputation was with Isaac Newton
the relationship between the two turned
sour
in 1672 when Newton presented his
notions on light and color Hooke
insisted that Newton's work was based on
ideas of his which he developed in 1665
the quarrel was only the appetizer
though as the main course came in 1687
when Isaac Newton published philosophy
naturalis principia mathematica
or simply the Principia arguably the
most famous book in the history of
science among several other principles
the Principia contains Newton's law of
universal gravitation an inverse-square
law that showed how planetary motion
worked it was a landmark moment in
physics but Hooke accused Newton of
plagiarism it is actually pretty hard to
establish how much credit if any should
go to hook by Newton's own admission he
corresponded with Herc on the matter but
he maintained the latter never provided
any new information he might have
concluded that an inverse-square law
govern the motion of the planets but he
never produced any proof for it even
though he claimed to have it this point
of view was corroborated by Edmund
Halley another esteemed scientist known
today for Halley's Comet he said that he
asked for proof from both Hooke and
Newton but only the latter delivered
pale you later encouraged Newton to ride
the ring
Kieran's financed its publication out of
his own pocket French astronomer Alexei
Claro was more tactful when dismissing
hoax claims saying that they showed us
what a distance there is between a truth
that is glimpsed and a truth that is
demonstrated
Hookes rivalry with Newton had a
negative effect on his image as well as
his standing in the scientific world
some of his later lectures revealed that
he never conceded the points that he
came up with the inverse square law
first and one of those lectures he said
concerning those properties of gravity
which I myself first discovered and
showed to this society and years since
which of late mr. Newton has done me the
favor to print and publish as his own
inventions Hooke gains a reputation of
being bitter and disgruntled he died in
1703 of an unspecified illness and was
buried at st. Helens bishop gate
although the exact location is unknown
soon afterwards another Royal Society
member name's Richard Walla published a
collection of hooks posthumous works and
included a short biography where he
described him as being melancholy
mistrustful and jealous this biography
the only one from a contemporary
influence to all those that followed but
we do not know the relationship between
Hooke and Walla as for Newton he became
president of the Royal Society the same
year that Hooke died and it is said that
he took steps to ensure that the world
would forget his former rival this may
have included the destruction of the
only known portrait of Robert Hooke so
that even as a likeness would be lost to
history but before we go on besmirching
newton's good name we should stress that
there is no solid evidence that he ever
did this or even that the portrait
existed in the first place other than
just a few mentions some have speculated
that Hooke never wanted to sit for a
portrait because in a week and miss
shapen body due to childhood illness
indeed today we have no idea what he
looked like this is the most famous
representation of Hooke based on the few
available descriptions but you might be
surprised to learn that this painting
done by Rita Grier is only 15 years old
she is one of the people who in recent
years have undertaken efforts to restore
Robert Hooke to his rightful place in
the pantheon of Britain's greatest
scholars so really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
smash that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe we got brand
new videos just like this four times a
week also do check out our fantastic
sponsor brilliance they are linked to
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]